it takes its toll being alone I'm a
little bit lost and it's finally time to
make a real connection Who am I I'm a
single white male 45 years of age I love
animals gainfully employed I'm a people
person I keep fit Who am I looking for
I'm looking for my idea mate are you
that idea that matches with who I really
am
how would you feel sure getting our
fingers dirty for a first date huh
gardening is the most therapeutic and
defiant act you can do people in these
areas they're exposed to crappy food I
want people to know that growing your
own foods like print your own money
you're like a food superhero food is the
problem and food is the solution
I'm a lexicographer my job is to put
every word possible into the dictionary
I love words too
I'm just as much as any LexA to talk
refer what if you love a word that
you've just made up like I don't know
scooper finkles do you think you see
reality well I'm a little nearsighted
but yeah well you can't I mean your
brain has no access to this world in
fact even the sensory information that
your eyes are receiving your ears are
receiving is completely meaningless
because it could mean anything that tree
could be a large object far away or a
small object up close your brain has no
way of knowing once I thought I saw a
Bigfoot but it was just a German
Shepherd bonobos are together with
chimpanzees you're living closest
relatives who neighbors have frequent
promiscuous sex to manage conflict and
solve social issues I'm just curious
do do we have any conflict that needs
managing or social issues to resolve
remember you're in a date with my idea
not me this is the face of someone who
against all odds is on the verge of an
epic win an epic win an epic win is an
outcome so extraordinarily positive you
didn't even know it was possible until
you achieved it you're not making the
face
and you're making me I'm not good at
life faith Arthur I want to be really
honest with you I am seeing other ideas
okay I'm dating around that's the
situation I'd say this mathematics is
not just solving for x it's also
figuring out why you want to get from pi
pi 3.14159265 three five eight nine
seven nine if we are going to do
something we've got to just make a
decision because without a decision
we're left powerless without power we
have nothing to supply the chain of
those who are truly curious to solve all
of our current conditions and if you
choose not to decide you still have made
a choice ruch yes this is the base we
need to see on millions of problem
solvers worldwide as we try to tackle
the challenges of the next century so we
going Dutch three eight four six two six
four three three eight three two seven
nine five zero two eight eight four one
nine two seven one when next we go to a
movie or something hell no let's go
plant some [ __ ] plant some [ __ ] it's
good now what is this and I'm planning
bonobos bonobos but now this interested
much
I want to have your idea baby well you
know what they say in Russia
scoober Finkel
you